boeing is expected to announce major
financial losses this morning because
the grounding of its 737 max aircraft
has lasted much longer than expected
those planes have been grounded
worldwide since mid-march following two
deadly crashes that killed 346 people
yesterday the president and CEO of
Boeing's commercial airline division was
replaced Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington was
more on this story Kris good morning to
you and what can we expect today
well good morning we know Boeing
executives will be addressing what is
likely to be in ugly financial quarter
marked by significant losses because of
the prolonged grounding of the 737 max
we also know that one executive will not
be on the call because the performance
has cost him his job Kevin McAllister is
out as the president and CEO of Boeing's
Commercial Airplanes division he faced
increasing internal scrutiny for what
many saw as his poor handling of
customer relationships and his
management of Boeing's most important
division during the 737 max crisis
commercial planes are more than 60
percent of Boeing's total revenue the
move to oust him comes just days after a
series of messages between two Boeing
test pilots from 2016 were made public
indicating there may have been problems
with the max's automated flight control
systems nearly two years before the
first crash one pilot wrote gets running
rampant in the sim on me speaking of a
simulator there and he worried its
performance meant he quote basically
lied to regulators unknowingly now this
month Boeing's president and CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg was stripped of his chairman
of the board title he remains in charge
of day-to-day operations and he is
expected to be testifying on the hill
next week Tony you can bet there will be
some tough questions waiting for him and
we'll be watching Chris thank you very
much